Q Byron Donald talking to Wolf Blitzer
who I'm told is not actually a wolf I
just found that out this morning about
the Biden document situation
thanks so much for joining us let me get
your reaction to the breaking news uh uh
you know you're a member of Congress you
deal with classified information what's
your reaction to this oh well my
reaction is pretty simple I'm wondering
why the vice president of the United
States had classified documents outside
of the hands of the intelligence
Community listen it's been pretty clear
that presidents do have some classified
documents but the difference between a
president and everybody else is the
president has the ability to declassify
information the vice president has no
ability to declassify information so
number one what was he doing with
classified information in his possession
number two why did it take six years and
I want to stress this for the American
people Joe Biden left the vice
presidency in 2017. so it's taken six
years for these documents to surface
that is incredibly concerning and point
number three and this is the one that's
most important everybody can go back to
the Hillary Clinton email Saga we know
other presidents have had classified
information but why was there a rate on
Mar-A-Lago but now this story just kind
of seeps out and everybody's saying oh
we just want to get down to the bottom
of it and everybody's giving the benefit
of the doubt a vice president of the
United States or a secretary of state or
anybody else should not be having
classified information
well Sunny hoston do you think he's the
darling of the Republican party just
because he's black or do you think it's
because he's an extremely good
communicator has a great handle on
what's going on here knows what he's
talking about and isn't afraid to say it
uh later on guys go back into that video
and watch you can see Wolf Blitzer he's
so depressed hearing truth that his his
face is actually starts to slide off his
skull
foreign
[Music]